this is something ellen degeneres
relives the darkest period of her
childhood when she says her stepfather
kicked down her door to molest her yeah
we've never heard Ellen get this candid
before but she hopes that she can help
others by sharing her traumatic story as
a victim of sexual abuse I am furious at
people who don't believe it I was 15
years old you know we are really
vulnerable at that age
Ellen opened up to this day show last
year about being sexually assaulted and
now she is sharing even more details in
a new sit-down interview with David
Letterman Ellen says her mother Betty
DeGeneres married quote a very bad man
when the comedian was just a teenager
Ellen says her mother was battling
breast cancer and her stepfather took
advantage of the diagnosis telling Ellen
he needed to check her breasts for lumps
what started with groping escalated she
said quote he tries to break my door
down and I kicked the window out and ran
when you are violated you don't know
what to do and you don't want to you
don't want to say anything because first
of all you just start wondering how
could did you know how did this happen
how was I that stupid Ellen didn't tell
her mother right away
she tells Letterman quote I was
protecting her and I knew that would
ruin her happiness when she did tell her
mom quote she didn't believe me and then
she stayed with him for 18 more years
and finally left him because he'd
changed the story so many times I think
we covered a lot more than I even
intended on covering the sit down drops
Friday on Netflix's my next two guests
needs no introduction with David
Letterman as for Ellen's relationship
with her mother the two of them have
grown closer over the years and the
comedian says Betty is apologetic for
not believing her sooner seeing all that
your daughter has done does she ever
amaze you I'm very proud very proud
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]